I didn't live you those your job let me
pick a puppet we went to live it to our
to nap mile hike I just got a really
good video with ro and we talked about
me a tea mac and cheese dummies
ketchup guys what are we going to do
today playing call dude I have no plans
I'm going to edit a bunch of videos and
then we can hang out and play yeah
I'm gonna go up and use Matt's fast
internet this is where I spent my whole
day right here on Jenna's couch are we
doing now get in bro yo that's a nice
painting John thank you I wanted a
violin not too much color do you wanna
go for a walk Maddie
good boy all right let's continue a lot
there's trees in here hi Jenna's getting
our Pinkberry because I had Maddie in
there and I had to fish a swedish fish
right out of his mouth now we have to go
deliver it to Matt he's streaming it's
hot and smelly in here this is really
delicious it was a very wise idea
Matt's a little bit of a slob like I'm a
slob too but like this is me oh I know
my places doesn't love we're saying
nothing is it that I'm obviously
anyone so now what do we do should I
just go home I gotta go get my Pokemon
Sun and Moon at home there it is
gift Matt always loses his Apple TV
remote so Jenna got him this they need
to make these four phones
don't you remember I used to have one in
my case my memory is small oh boy
just made it home opening up my packages
so this is pretty incredible because I
got the Apple book and then I started
getting a little bit more intrigued in
some of the other things that I was like
super into and kind of going back into
sort of my childhood I found this
amazing book it's the playing with power
in Tendo NES classics I've been having a
lot of nostalgia lately especially with
the NES classic edition so I just I
wanted to just check this book out so
I'm sure some of you who are around my
age or grew up in the same era used to
get the Nintendo Power subscription it
was the coolest thing ever I got two
subscriptions when I was younger I got
in Tendo power and I got Macworld
Macworld who's really my only like
inside insight to anything that was
going on in the Apple world because the
internet wasn't really like a thing it's
like shaped like old classic cartridge
focus inside here this is cool it shows
you like every level
oh my gosh
it has all of the levels laid out flat
it's the little things that excite me
I'll put you back in here because you're
going to stay protected and in here oh
boy so I'm trying to make something but
here's the problem I don't know how to
cut metal so if anybody on the Westside
in Los Angeles can assist me with
cutting some metal or perhaps 3d
printing some things for Matt I'm trying
to make something for this camera that
I've been testing out it's almost the
perfect log in camera but there's just a
little something that needs to be done
to it
did you have a fun day today do you know
what time it is
it's Pokemon Sun and Moon time okay
take my MacBook upstairs and I'm gonna
edit in bed I don't make my bed when I
wake up I have to make it before I go to
bed cuz I like to get in bed and it'd be
nice and perfectly made I was in my room
and I heard this little bark and
somebody wants to play do you see a
diamond paint immunity what do you do
when you want good sit high five I've
got mail wait will you come celebrate my
birthday at 11:24 all right well I guess
I'll go to bed now and download my game
there
just somebody want to wake up now you
want me to wake up is that what you want
get your mouth fuel to me wake up to a
mommy to wake up mm-hmm is it time for
breakfast okay let's get breakfast good
morning everyone
my d/s is about to die I'm hoping the
Pokemon Center move downloaded last
night just silly looking real good this
morning feeling the feeling really brush
I'm gonna make some eggs but I'm also
making one for the dark
you want some 80s this one's for the
gone
sit
good boy now I can have my breakfast
well it's started the progression of
moving towards using my MacBook Pro with
touch bar as my main computer but the
problem is as most of everyone has been
talking about is the dongle gate my
dongle gate has currently already
started I'm currently using one of the
monitors that I used to use in my
trashcan Mac which not too long ago made
me like eight months ago I thought that
the trashcan Mac was going to be it's
called the Mac Pro for the record but I
think everyone does call it the trashcan
although my sister called her a water
cooler heater water heater I really
thought this thing was gonna be it was
gonna up my productivity but it actually
has hindered it because it takes so long
to export and compress videos in Final
Cut Pro X that is the worst purchase
that I've ever made in my entire life
and I've bought a lot of stupid things I
bought a $300 book of photos of Apple
products so if I say it's worthless
you know it's real what I've got going
on over here is I have a USB C hard
drive hooked into my macbook pro which
because I do love editing off of
external drives but to use this monitor
I have to use a converter which converts
from USB C to Thunderbolt so now I can
power the monitor but my mouse is dead
so to charge this I needed a lightning
cable to converts to USB C but since I
was out of USB C port because I've got
my USB hub plugged in i de plug in the
USB C to the hub because to my computer
it's there's a lot of things going on
here but for the most part I've been
extremely happy with this computer like
a and just I'm super happy I've been
editing a lot quicker
I've been exporting a lot faster I got
my bag of dongles which I did post on
Instagram which was kind of funny
because I always have a Chico bag of
cords I have a to-go bag of cords with
basically anything that I'm gonna need
at any given point during a day of
filming or shooting or charging I've got
a micro I've got USB see I've got mini
I've got USB three I've even got a
little apple watch charger and the most
surprising I also have got a USB charger
for the Nintendo 3ds and also one of the
DS's expert headphones and also
batteries for probably any camera that
I'm going to have with me got my canon
g7x of course the battery that I have in
this camera would also usually be in
here as well and one for my Sony I've
got a nice little USB 3 a converter 2
USB and of course my iPhone dongle an
extra USB card reader some earrings in
case I feel like being like a pretty
princess that day I might have to do
some reorganization I've been using the
tux bar on and off it's kind of hard to
East you because I kind of forget that
it's there sometimes one of the things
that I thought was gonna be a little bit
annoying is the track packs it's so huge
I actually really like it so props to be
massive trackpad I do really like it I
also do gonna apologize to anyone who
was watching my macbook touch bar review
video where I've kept calling the
MacBook the MacBook Air because for
whatever reason even back when I first
got that thing a year ago I kept calling
it a MacBook Air because to me that was
a freaking MacBook Air not a MacBook you
removed the pork you made it smaller you
made it thinner you made it smaller than
the freaking in MacBook Air so I was
joking the whole time calling this thing
the MacBook Air and then I actually
forgot that it was just the MacBook I
feel like Apple needs to really figure
out their product line names because
it's getting confusing if it's confusing
to someone who basically lives their
life I live or die by Apple you know I
and I get them confused
imagine a normal consumer who was going
into the store and they're trying to
figure out what they need just a thought
anyway my dongles and I are gonna go
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you didn't that's okay I'll post another
one probably tomorrow or the next day
that'll be well that you like that's
sort of my philosophy here on YouTube I
post a lot of different content from
tech reviews to cooking to logs to I
have no idea a lot of things some things
aren't for everybody and I'm totally ok
with that
but I do like to try to pull something
for you guys every day but I don't like
to say that I'm going to pose every day
because then if I skip a day I don't
want to feel bad about it so if I
don't commit myself to posting every day
then I don't have to well see raise my
next video I am so excited to show you
guys a video that I have coming out very
soon that I'm working on it's actually a
review of this camera that I'm vlogging
on right now so I can't wait to show it
to you because I'm super into it I see
you guys later bye oh my goodness leave
it down here so quickly as good as my
little wheels could spin and there is an
absolutely massive line Jenna's on her
way I'm a little bit nervous because I